Now remember earlier when we
were talking about stock value,
or I should say company value.
And we looked at a way to compute
company value based on dividends.
So companies pay regularly,
many companies,
not all, dividends to their owners.
And this can be worth a lot of money.
So a stock that's priced
at say around $100,
can very often pay up to $1 or
$2 per year in dividends, or 1 or 2%.
Some stocks pay even more than that.
Now dividends can have
a significant affect
on what happens to the actual price
of the stock, and here's why.
Suppose this stock is
trading at about $100.
And they announce,
on this date in the future,
we're going to pay a $1 dividend.
So for every share of stock
that you own, you'll get $1.
What do you think is going to happen to
the price of this stock between now and
the date of that dividend?
Let me give you a little bit
more information that might make
things simpler.
Let's suppose that the consensus
on the value of the company,
by whatever means you've
determined that consensus,
is that the company is
worth $100 per share.
So on this date, in order to we get
that $1 dividend, we're going to have
one share of the company that people
think is worth $100 per share and
we will have $1.
So on this date, we'll have one share of
a company supposedly worth $100 and $1.
So think about it.
What prices will we see
this stock converge to
on the day before the dividend is paid
and the day the dividend is paid?